diesen ball oman mitgestalten und man
muss dazu sagen von anfang an ist das
ein tool gewesen bei denen sich junge
menschen nahmen einbringen können und
jeder der sozusagen jünger als 26 jahre
und wahlberechtigt ist darf eben an in
dieser baumart redaktion mitwirken das
haben sich wieder annähern 400 leute
beworben
und ja wird sozusagen eine gruppe von
ausgewählt und die setzt sich in einem
mehrtägigen workshop mit experten
zusammen wertet die wahlprogramme der
parteien aus vergleicht positionen wo
sich die parteien voneinander
unterscheiden und experten aus
journalismus
bildung und auch aus statistik
gründen haben wir da eben auch sozusagen
solche experten die sich mit
statistik design beschäftigen er
integriert wir haben eine begleitung der
universität düsseldorf schon seit langer
zeit seit vielen jahren die den wahlomat
evaluieren und damit auch impuls gegeben
für die jeweils anstehenden
veränderungen und verbesserungen des
monats also ist sehr professionell ist
ihm aber entfernt es ist eine
jugendredaktion die sich mit diesen
themen aussucht weil wir wollten mit
diesem angebot
eine stärkung jugendliche über
wahlbeteiligung versuchen an zu regnen
das ist glaube ich auch gelungen bis
heute gehört die gruppe der jugendlichen
zu den hauptnutzern das war damals aber
es ist längst kein
ausschließlich von jungen benutztes tool
mittlerweile ist jeder vierte rentner
den vierte rentnerin
sehr fröhlich und gut und fleißig
unterwegs beim war normal wahlomat um
sich eben selbst zu vergleichen und ich
finde das ist am ende des tages auch ein
stück eine demokratisierung geschichte
letztendlich bestimmte aspekte man gar
nicht so auf dem schirm hat wenn man
sich für eine partei entscheidet oder
eben nicht entscheidet und diese
informationen denke ich sehr hilfreich
man kann vor und recht sagen der
wahlomat ist das erfolgreichste angebot
politischer bildung seite geben als die
bundeszentrale für politische bildung
gibt
ja das erfolgreichste angebot seit es
die bundeszentrale für politische
bildung gibt thomas krüger im kleinen
vor gespräch das ich gesagt vorher mit
ihm geführt habe dann klein statement
ein bisschen 'schon vorausblickend auf
das was wir jetzt auch gleich in der
pressekonferenz erzählen werden wie der
wahl o maten steht wie er wirkt was
seine idee ist ja ich freue mich sehr
dass wir die kolleginnen und kollegen
mit dabei haben die den wahlomat
mitentwickelt haben in den letzten
wochen und monaten
wir haben redakteurinnen und redakteure
aus der wähler ist er aus der
redaktionsgruppe zusammen mit dir dabei
vor allen dingen zwei jüngeren
mitglieder dieser redaktions runde bevor
wir mit den beiden sprechen werden wir
einmal ganz kurz mit meinen kolleginnen
und kollegen aus der projektleitung des
wahl-o-mat sprechen
martin pamela lea ihr habt jetzt erst
mal das wort erzählt ein bisschen was
ist der wahlomat wie kommt er zu stande
was könnt ihr uns heute morgen mit geben
vielen daniel wir wollen heute ein
bisschen zeigen wie der wahlomat in das
jahr 20 21 geht wir haben ein super
wahljahr nicht nur die bundestagswahl
sondern auch viele landtags fahren und
da haben wir den ball
und nicht nur neuen anstrich verpasst
sondern haben auch
inhaltlich und konzeptionell ein
bisschen neu aufgestellt
das ist der wahlomat wenn man die
startseite sieht ich glaube ich gut
wiederzuerkennen mit dem orangenen
kasten in den sieht man ganz gut und wir
haben dieses jahr in ballarat im
bundestag 12 39 von 40 parteien
inbegriffen das heißt nahezu alle
parteien sind wieder dabei nur eine
partei wollte nicht mitmachen
die handelsvolumen sind nach wie vor die
die thesen 38 thesen zu denen man sich
eben zustimmend neutralen oder ablehnt
positionieren kann oder auch
überspringen das überspringen können die
parteien natürlich nicht die haben nur
diese drei auswahl positionen was wir im
wald zum beispiel hier neu gestaltet
haben ist dass wir ein eigens einführen
also dass die nutzer den nutzer immer
bescheid wissen
für was das symbol steht das heißt wenn
sie hier auf neutral gehen mit unten
auch schon dass das chlor für neutral
angezeigt das dann später auch wieder
wiederverwendet wird das gleiche für
für die zustimmung oder auch letzte
these für die ablehnung das sehen sie
unten das weiße iks auf roten grund
was sie weiterhin haben ist die
gewichtung der thesen das heißt sie
können die die thesen in einer
bestimmten wertigkeit auch einführen
eine these die sie hier die sie
hervorheben also wenn ich zum beispiel
sagen die these patentschutz für
impfstoffe ist mir doppelt wichtig dann
wird er hier auch mit mit einem
doppelten gewichtung eingenommen oder
parteispenden das es erlaubt sein soll
ist mir wichtig
haben sie das hier weiter weiter
gewichten
was weiterhin gibt es die auswahl der
parteien das heißt das angebot an die
nutzerin nutzer sich intensiv selbst mit
den parteien wird zu beschäftigen bevor
sie sie im ergebnis sehen das
ermöglichen wir hier dadurch auch dass
wir so einen kleinen info text der
partei geben und hier auch auf partei-
profile verlinken die von
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftlern
verfasst wurden wo die partei noch ein
bisschen genauer charakterisiert werden
sie können
wieder jede partei einzeln auswählen
oder wenn sie sich nicht für einzel
parteien interessieren natürlich auch
unten mit einem haken alle parteien in
die auswahl mit rein nehmen
und mit einem klick weiter erhalten sie
ergebnis dass hier ein bisschen animiert
aufgebaut wird und wie bekannt in einem
balkendiagramm daher kommt auch wieder
mit den anmerkungen zu den parteien so
dass es sich im ergebnis intensiv
auseinandersetzen können
nach manchen hetterich hat es ja am
anfang schon angesprochen dieses jahr
gibt es einige neue funktionen im wal
mart die einen spielerischen zugang
bieten damit man sein ergebnis besser
verstehen kann und auch mehr über
parteien und über die themen erfährt
eins davon dass das tuning
und das tuning bietet ihnen die
möglichkeit an verschiedenen
stellschrauben zu drehen und dann zu
sehen was das mit ihrem ergebnis macht
sie sehen auf der einen seite ihre
positionen und ihre gewichtung auf der
anderen seite ihr ergebnis und könne
neben ihre positionen ändern
beispielsweise und seen direkt was dann
passiert auf der seite ihres ergebnis
wurde können auch ihre gewichtung
verändern und so ganz viele kleine
schrauben drehen und es herausfinden an
welchen punkten liegt es denn dass wir
zu diesem ergebnis gekommen sind können
ihre eigenen gewichtung einbeziehen oder
nicht und können auch entscheiden ob sie
sich an der stelle alle parteien
angeboren vielleicht nur die patente
nicht im bundestag sind oder die
parteien die im bundestag sind
das neues feature ist der partei nicht
mehr gleich und dazu sagt jetzt meine
kolleginnen kombi auf angriff
im vergleich sind wir der frage
nachgegangen wie eigentlich die beiden
stimmung zwischen den parteien
stattfindet vorausgewählt sind die erste
und zweite parteien in meinem
persönlichen ranking ich kann natürlich
auch eine dritte hinzufügen oder einfach
ganz neue auswählen welche bis zu drei
parteien ich mir einfach zusammen
angucken möchte also jeder jede der
position des freibäder hier sehe ich
einfach drei cluster gespannt wie ich
volle übereinstimmung aller drei
parteien
ich kann natürlich auch gucken
welche teilweise übereinstimmung sie
haben oder eben überhaupt keine
übereinstimmung das ist ja für viele
sehr interessant vor allem wenn sie dann
erst an zweiter stelle oder dritter
stelle parteien haben die sie vielleicht
überrascht haben in der nähe man kann
sich natürlich zusätzlich dann sofort
angucken wie denn die begründung waren
der drei parteien wenn man zwischen zu
der einen these diese zwei hier und kann
sie die gleiche welche votum hat
eventuell sehr unterschiedliche
begründungen oder die ablehnung geben
noch mal eine andere das kann man jetzt
aber einen blick sehr spielerisch
nachfolge und man kann natürlich auch
zusätzlich schauen mich wie war ich denn
eigentlich dazu positioniert ich kann
mich noch mal vergleichen da sieht man
dass in der diese selbst ist das weil
man das icon zu sehen das war meine
position auch ob ich gewinne oder nicht
und dann sieht man wo ich denn mit
meinen drei parteien durch berater
ausgesucht habe übereinstimmt hat oder
wo ich völlig konträr war
und nun eine begründung
gibt er schränkt aber
die begründung steht die frage im
mittelpunkt wie sich alle parteien zu
den einzelnen thesen positionieren das
heißt ich kann dann als nutzerin zum
beispiel überlegen die these tempolimit
auf autobahnen das ist ein thema was
mich besonders interessiert da bin ich
jetzt wissen was sagen eigentlich die
einzelnen parteien dazu und kann da eben
sehen die parteien sind sortiert nach
ihrer position dass stimme zu stimme
neutral oder stimmen nicht zu und kann
auch sehen wie ich mich eigentlich
positioniert habe und dann eben für jede
partei die begründungen ausklappen
lassen und mir anschauen was ihre motive
sind für diese position ich kann auch da
entscheiden welche parteien nicht
besonders interessieren und kann ebenso
mir die argumente ansehen die es gibt
für eine these das ist spannend weil es
eben manchmal eine position gibt also
zum beispiel stimmen parteien zu sie
haben aber vielleicht ganz andere gründe
dafür und
ein bisschen anderen blickwinkel auf
diese thesen liefern dann die
standpunkte
dort kann man eben überlegen gibt es
eine partei nicht mehr besonders genau
ich kann sie wieder oben auswählen alle
parteien die automat vertreten sind so
weit zugelassen sind und dann sehe ich
zum beispiel hier der cdu csu die
gemeinsam auf die wahl o maten
geantwortet haben die sie zu den 38
thesen begründet haben quasi eine partei
einen blick aber ich kann mir auch jeder
andere ausspielen lassen ich sehe dort
einmal noch das votum der partei in
diesem moment tempolimit ja und dann die
begründung dazu hier sehen sie es dann
zu den 38 diesen ab einem blick wichtig
ist wie immer die wahl o maten wurden
von den parteien selbst beantwortet und
auch die begründung selbst geschrieben
und frisiert sie vergleichen also sich
mit den autorisierten antworten der
parteien
diese erstellung wie sie vielleicht
sehen können das war doch matze hat fast
ein halbes jahr gedauert wir sind lange
dabei alles vorzubereiten alle zur wahl
zugelassen oder die in die die es
vorhatten parteien zu kontaktieren wir
haben einen bewerbungsphase für die
jugendredaktion wir sammeln alle
wahlprogramme unter vorläufigen
wahlprogramme der parteien
analysieren sie und bereiten den
workshop vor und am ende den 35 personen
die balance redaktion vier tage oder
insgesamt jetzt sogar fünf tage in zwei
workshops digitalen wirtschaft haben wir
zusammen gearbeitet also drei die die
thesen entwickelt sondern eine riesige
redaktion davon sind es heuer 14
politikexperten experten die
dabei waren aber genauso auch 19
jugendliche in erster und zweiter innen
und wlan von denen einige hier da sind
und denen ich gerne jetzt das wort geben
möchte
ja vielen dank pamela brandleger schrenk
und martin ellerich er bleibt ja
weiterhin suchen dabei das heißt die
fragen die jetzt auch auftauchen können
wir dann alle auch noch im laufe der
session beantworten und anschließend
gibt es ja auch eine möglichkeit mit
euch auch noch mal ein break out room zu
sprechen also alle die fragen die auch
im chat schon gestellt werden gerne rein
stellen wir sammeln die und beantworten
sie dann entsprechend jetzt hast du
angesprochen es gibt eine
jugendredaktion und meine kollegin marie
theres grün wird grüne wird jetzt ganz
kurz mal mit dem jugendredakteurin den
beiden die dabei sind ins gespräch
kommen ich übergebe an dich mary
ja vielen dank ich fixiere
beziehungsweise zugeschaltet bin ich
hier einmal eine marigol aus hamburg und
alina langenberg aus gummersbach und
beide waren eben als junglehrerin teil
der band redaktion und annemarie ich du
dich einfach mal direkt als erstes
fragen wie bist du dazu gekommen die ich
bei der wal mart redaktion zu bewerben
und mitzumachen
ich bin tatsächlich durch zufall darauf
gestoßen
weil mich einfach interessiert hat wann
der wahl denn eigentlich online geht und
genau dann war gerade die ausschreibung
für das bewerbungsverfahren und dann
dachte ich ich bewerbe mich einfach mal
denn ich finde es gerade bei dieser
bundestagswahl
super wichtig sich auch als junger
mensch zu engagieren gerade weil meine
generation ja eigentlich gar keine
andere bundeskanzlerin als angela merkel
so wirklich kennt
ja das kann ich mir gut vorstellen und
ich glaube das war auch im total das
spannende prozent mehr ebenso ein
bisschen schon in bagdad bahn gehört
alina wasser nicht nur die großen
herausforderungen bei dem ganzen
entwickeln der thesen und der auswahl
gute frage also es gab sehr viele
herausforderungen nicht denkt so zu
beginn war die größte herausforderung
aus der menge an wahlprogramm und dann
themen die dieses jahr besprochen und
diskutiert werden so die kern das
fenster oder herausfinden und auch das
herauszufiltern was für die gesellschaft
am wichtigsten so wo sich alle parteien
zu äußern
dann diese ganzen themen bin wirklich
ein oder zwei satz thesen zu packen und
das ganze so zu formulieren dass es
wirklich jeder versteht oder am besten
fall jeder versteht und dass man kein
experte und in dem bereich sein muss das
war
die weitere herausforderung ich glaube
so gerade zum schluss in den workshops
ging es dann darum zu gucken dass man
die
parteien untereinander abgrenzt die sich
doch sehr nahe stehen also dass man es
schafft auch im hinblick auf die thesen
formulierung parteien dass ich doch sehr
ähnlich sind trotzdem noch voneinander
abzugrenzen sind also sehr sehr
spannende aber definitiv auch nicht
einfach
ja das kann ich mir vorstellen wenn du
jetzt so auf dass er auf die letzten
monate zurück liegt damit auf der zeit
also für mich war vor allem die vielfalt
an menschen die in der redaktion sind
total spannend da kommt man wirklich
noch mal so aus seiner babbel in der man
sich mal fliegt raus und lernt halt
menschen kennen die an ganz anderen
punkten in ihrem leben stehen und ganz
andere erfahrungen gesammelt haben
dadurch auch anders geprägt wurde das
war für mich ein super super spannend
und total schön auch so diese vielfalt
an menschen kannst du da noch mit ihnen
arbeiten zu dürfen
manama dpa das für dich ja ich kann da
alina auf jeden fall nur zustimmen was
mich auch noch sehr ja was ich einfach
auch spannend fand war gerade durch
statistische werte auch die engsten
parteien paare zu unterscheiden und halt
ja diese bestmöglich voneinander
abzugrenzen das war auch gar nicht so
einfach aber ich würde mal überhaupt nah
am ende haben wir das gut hinbekommen
aber
dann danke ich euch total toll dass ihr
dabei war und dann scheint ich jetzt
einmal zurück an daniel kraft bzw er
schaltet jetzt einmal nach düsseldorf so
ist es vielen dank mary für das kurze
gespräch mit den beiden redakteurinnen
aus der jugendredaktion und wir schalten
jetzt zu
professor doktor stefan marschall nach
düsseldorf an die dortige universität
viele der fragen die auch schon gestellt
wurden da wird er bestimmt jetzt gleich
was zu sagen stichwort
qualitätssicherung stichworte
wissenschaftlich überwachung stichwort
wie wirkt eigentlich der wahlomat stefan
erzählt uns ein bisschen dazu was ihr in
den letzten jahr inzwischen jahrzehnten
an wahlomat forschung betrieben habt
denn der wahlomat ist ein projekt der
bpb was von anfang an ein über sehr sehr
lange schon wissenschaftlich begleitet
wurde ihr wisst sehr sehr viel über den
wahlomat obwohl wir und das sagen wir
noch mal an der stelle sehr deutlich
ganz ganz wenig speichern das heißt im
wahlomat wird eigentlich gar nichts
gespeichert keine daten kein
nutzerverhalten aber ihr macht
repräsentative umfragen dazu was macht
dir genau
das macht ihn so ist es wir machen
umfragen wir machen bald forschung hier
in düsseldorf das machen wir seit 2010
hier an der heinrich-heine-universität
ich persönlich mache das schon seit 2003
und insofern haben wir tatsächlich da
schon relativ viele erkenntnisse was die
nutzung des waldes angeht gewinnen die
dadurch dass wir im anschluss an die
wahl o mat nutzung nutzerinnen nutzer
einladen an einer befragung teilzunehmen
und dann fragen wir die einschränkungen
fahren auch in richtung warum sie den
ballon nach genutzt haben und wir mit
welcher wirkung sie das getan haben
insofern gibt es ja seit anfang an
eigentlich eine wissenschaftliche
begleitung dieses tools und dadurch gibt
es auch einige erkenntnis die wir
gesammelt haben ich würde es einfach mal
gerne meinen bildschirm teilen um zu
zeigen was wir bei der letzten
bundestagswahl als ergebnisse hatten es
ist klar wir haben natürlich jetzt noch
keine ergebnisse der aktuellen
wahlomat ist dabei der jetzt gerade das
gestartet ist und deswegen einfach mal
einen blick auf das was wir beim letzten
mal bei der letzten beim letzten einsatz
bei einer bundestagswahl an ergebnissen
herausgefunden haben und ich will
einfach mal zwei drei folien teilen und
dann gerne stehe ich auch noch für
andere fragen zur verfügung ist dass
mindestens später auch in den breakout
sessions gut also erst mal fragen wie im
nu möglicherweise nutzt man den ballon
und tatsächlich ist es soweit der
bundestagswahl 20 17 waren die gründe
der wichtigste grund für die meisten den
standpunkt den eigenen standpunkt zu
überprüfen mit dem standpunkt der partei
die einem nahe steht also viele wollen
einfach mal sich ein bisschen
orientieren wo steht die partei von der
ich vermute das seminar steht vertritt
die auch die gleichen position oder hat
es ja irgendwie andere ideen was die
wichtigen themen der wahl angeht und
andere sachen sind ihr etwas nachhaltig
wie man hier sehr gut sehen kann
lieberman schritt weiter dann fragen wie
man wie haben sie die balance gefunden
hat dann eben weitergeholfen in welcher
form hatte ihnen weitergeholfen und bei
der bundestagswahl 20 17 ist es so dass
fast zwei drittel gesagt haben der warte
mal hilft einem die unterschiede
zwischen den parteien besser zu erkennen
und das ist ja ein ganz zentrales ziel
dieses tools klar zu machen es macht
einen unterschied welche parteien ich
werde nicht alle parteien sind gleich
das sagen zumindest zwei drittel derer
die bei uns in der befragung
teilgenommen haben auch bundespolitische
themen aufmerksam gemacht das sind 50,8
prozent gewesen damals das heißt
ungefähr die hälfte sagt jetzt sind in
die themen des wahlkampfs klarer
geworden und ja spaß gemacht immerhin 80
prozent sagen dass von sich und
vielleicht noch eine letzte folie das
ist die frage wie weit der wahlomat dann
auch politische beteiligung und
überhaupt ganz einstellen generell
vielleicht verändern kann und da haben
wir festgestellt dass drei viertel der
rabbi bei uns an der befragung
teilgenommen haben sagen sie werden über
das ergebnis mit anderen sprechen die
hälfte sagt das motiviert so weiter core
politische informationen damals haben
dann fünf prozent gesagt eigentlich
hatten sie vorher nicht vorgehabt zur
wahl zu gehen der wahlomat hat sie dann
davon überzeugt dass doch zu tun das
hört sich jetzt nach wenig an aber dazu
muss man wissen dass relativ viele den
wahlomat nutzen auch an der wahl
teilnehmen wollen wenn man jetzt nur die
raus greift die sagt sie wollen
eigentlich nicht an der wahlomat an der
wahl teilnehmen sie wollen nicht ihre
stimme abgeben dann sind es rund 50
prozent derer die dann doch überzeugt
werden zur wahl zu gehen an der wahl
teilzunehmen und ja das ist sagt da gibt
es mobilisierende effekte des tools
hinsichtlich der wahlbeteiligung aber
auch in sich der anderen branchen
kommunikation die man dann betreibt und
der information die man dann auch
einsammeln möchte sie heute erst einmal
von mir erste ergebnisse wie gesagt das
mal ergebnisse aus 20 17 wir machen auch
in einer befragung 20 21 ist klar und
dann wissen wir dann auch mehr ob sich
da etwas ändert aber sind relativ
stabile ergebnisse die wir auch auf der
ebene der landtagswahl mate sehen und
auch bei der europawahl erst mal soweit
meinerseits
bank professor stefan marschall von der
universität düsseldorf für die
langjährige begleitung und auch den
kurzen einblick das ist sicherlich dann
auch schon eine erste antwort auf die
frage die unternehmen zb andreas lutz
gerade gestellt hat also
qualitätssicherung was machen sie
systematisch in diesem bereich wir sind
so weit jetzt erstmal durch unser
programm durch und ich würde jetzt
einfach mal noch mal alle
redaktionsmitglieder die da sind oder
die projektleitung auch noch mal hin zu
holen und wird mal ein paar der fragen
die schon mal gestellt wurden versuchen
zu beantworten ich würde sagen wir
machen das so fünf minuten lang fünf bis
zehn minuten lang und dann gibt es die
möglichkeit in breakout ruhms zum einen
mit den jungen redakteurinnen und
redakteuren nochmal zu sprechen aber
auch er als projektleitung stehen zur
verfügung und auch professor stephan
schad steht noch mal vereinzelt fragen
im direkten gespräch zur verfügung die
sie natürlich auch mit aufzeichnen
können das ist völlig okay hier an
dieser stelle also ich will noch mal
wieder beim eda brand auf die bühne
sozusagen mit dazu martin hetterich
wohlig mit dazu und lehrer schränkt das
heißt wir versuchen jetzt mal die fragen
zu beantworten die sie gestellt haben
erste frage ist wie haben sie auf die
kritik von kleinparteien reagiert ja
immer wieder sich mal benachteiligt
fühlen wer möchte pamela martin
familie
die kleinpartei 2009 10 jahren wahlomat
oder schon länger seit 2009 sind weil
alle parteien mit drin am 2009 10 kann
man auch alle gleichzeitig auswählen wir
hatten so immer die möglichkeit vorher
gehabt dass man das auswählen konnte
seit 2009 10 kriegt man alle auf einen
blick
ich glaube der wahlomat ist in der tat
es mittlerweile ein tool und es ist
schon seit jahren so der kleinen
parteien besonders in den fokus
ausstellt in einen raum gibt sich zu
präsentieren oftmals gehen sie ja in
vielen öffentlichen debatten unter weil
dann nur die großen parteien zu wort
kommen im wahl-o-mat haben sie die
gleichen chancen wie alle anderen auf
die balance zu antworten auch diese
antworten zu begründen 50 prozent gibt
ja aus den umfragen wissen der
nutzerinnen nutzen lesen auch diese
begründung ich glaube es ein riesiges
forum für die kleinen parteien und das
wird genutzt und ich persönlich finde
auch dass es sehr spannend ist nun
feedback was wir bekommen dass die leute
sagen ja dass die partei kannte ich gar
nicht aber jetzt habe ich sie
kennengelernt durch den wahlomat wir
haben ja auch wie magnete rich erzählte
kurze parteiprofil stellen also alle zur
wahl zugelassenen parteien kurz vor das
ist auch glaube ich ein angebot was sehr
angenommen wird weil man sich manchmal
den namen von der kleinen parteien wenig
vorstellen kann und so bieten wir glaube
ich ein gutes informationspaket für
kleine parteien aber eben für alle
parteien gleich und gleichwertig angeht
so weit zugelassen sind
vielen dank wlan jetzt eine weitere
frage die schon auch in den letzten
tagen das aber natürlich mitbekommen
auch in den sozialen medien und an
verschiedenen stellen immer wieder
kritisch diskutiert wurde wieso wird der
wahlomat erst zu spät veröffentlicht
viele brief wählerinnen und wähler
hätten bereits gerät wird gesagt bisher
haben waren hauptsächlich ältere
menschen briefe wäre aber in der
pandemiewelle sehr viele menschen per
briefwahl das ist schade dass der warnow
märz so spät kommt warum kommt er zu
spät oder kommt er überhaupt zu spät
martin vielleicht mal
ja gerne wir arbeiten natürlich schon
sehr lange mit den mit den parteien
zusammen das heißt wir haben schon im
märz oder februar in den kontakt zu den
parteien gesucht und und sie um
programmatische vorlagen gebeten und das
orientieren insgesamt die die phasen des
wal mart und natürlich auch die
veröffentlichung heute sehr eng an die
an die terminpläne die uns zum einen
gesetzlich vorgegeben sind es gibt einen
bestimmten abschnitt zulassungsverfahren
für die parteien das dann mehrstufig ist
und zum anderen natürlich auch an die
vorarbeit der parteien dh wenn wir in
die in die arbeit in die inhaltliche
arbeit gehen dann ist es oft noch der
punkt dass die parteien ihre programme
noch gar nicht veröffentlicht haben wir
von den parteien dann oftmals vorab
entwürfe der programme oder vielleicht
die ideen parteitags antrag der dann das
programm enthält und so arbeiten wir
eigentlich schon relativ früh wenn die
programme noch gar nicht offen sind
daran aus diesen programmen die die
besten thesen herauszuarbeiten und zu
erstellen
und sind dann auch mit den phasen das
war damals sehr eng an die zulassung
zugelassen wenn ich das richtig im kopf
habe ist glaube ich die finale zulassung
die letzte einspruchsmöglichkeit war
irgendwann in der ersten oder zweiten
augustwoche das heißt ab da können wir
wirklich erst final an den thesen
arbeiten denn auch der die thesen
zuschnitt der die 38 thesen die dann am
ende im banat inbegriffen sind können
wir natürlich erst richtig auswählen
wenn wir wissen welche parteien dabei
sind weil wir natürlich diese parteien
unterscheiden wollen und alle phasen der
der qualitätssicherung die auch zum
beispiel bei professor marshall in
düsseldorf laufen sich alle partei
antworten anzusehen das braucht
natürlich einiges an zeit und da gehen
wir lieber sorgfältig vor und haben den
wahlomat heute veröffentlicht was wir
schon vor einer woche veröffentlicht
haben das sind die beiden wahlen die
version zu den wahlen in berlin und in
mecklenburg vorpommern
da ist natürlich der aufwand gerade auch
mit blick auf die weniger parteien ein
bisschen geringer das konnte man dann
vorziehen und so haben wir auch den
beiden ländern so ein bisschen die eine
plattform gegeben und ihnen ermöglicht
nicht nur im schatten des zwangs zur
bundestagswahl zu stehen sondern auch
eine woche für sich kleinsten zu können
dank martin vielleicht auch dahingehend
noch mal wieder wirklich der mehrfach
auch von uns schon gegebene hinweis der
wahlomat ist ein informationsangebot und
jeder der jetzt sagt oh gott ich muss
schon brief wählen es gibt auch viele
viele andere angebote mit denen man sich
informieren kann es ist ein baustein von
vielen und wir freuen uns natürlich über
die große ehre und aber auch das muss
man an der stelle noch mal sagen es ist
niemals gedacht als irgendwie hilfe zur
entscheidung sondern um wirklich als
informationstool in diese richtung jetzt
gibt es eine frage von martin kessler
der fragt die werden die als in
themenbereiche bei den fragen gerichtet
also eben politik aus politik wirtschaft
soziales gesellschaft kultur
recht wer möchte dazu etwas sagen
wir
nein aber dafür ist kann interessante
noch mal kurz in die debatte überhaupt
entsteht wir hatten ja schon kurz
erklärt dass wir in einer redaktion an
diesen thesen arbeiten in einer
redaktion im osten jungen wählerinnen
aus den expertinnen und experten aus den
verantwortlichen der bundeszentrale
haben wir uns eben schon anfang juni
getroffen und auf basis der
programmatischen aussagen der parteien
aber auch auf diskussionen die eben
gerade gesellschaftlich interessant sind
in verschiedenen thematischen gruppen
gearbeitet also wir teilen uns eben auch
zum beispiel in eine gruppe die sich mit
familie gesund wird und so weiter eine
gruppe die sich mit verkehr wohnen
beschäftigt also nach politikfeldern
aufgeteilt in letter rein schauen uns
die programme an und erarbeiten eben auf
der basis thesen nicht so formuliert
sind dass man sich dazu positionieren
kann die gehen dann an die parteien 80
stück an der zahl die parteien müssen
sich dann dazu positionieren und wenn
wir eben wissen welche parteien zur wahl
antreten treffen wir uns nochmal zu
einem auswahl workshop und suchen dann
daraus die parteien an die thesen aus
die besonders gut unterscheiden auf der
ein würde das ist ein kriterium aber
eben auch das ganze spektrum an themen
die in einem wahlkampf trat entscheidend
sind auch abdecken also es geht nicht
nur rein um statistische werte adomat
sondern eben auch darum dass wir eben
einen guten überblick über ein
wahlkampfteam bieten können
jetzt habe ich zwei fragen die ich mal
bündeln würde und ein stefan escher
weiter reichen würde wer eine hinweis
ist ich habe den ball und genutzt und
war darüber sehr überrascht ja schreibt
ein nutzer jetzt hier geht es vielen so
lieber stefan ist meine frage an dich
also gibt es diesen überraschungseffekt
für vielen da wird ja gerne auch mal in
den letzten tagen auch in den social
media behauptet wie sieht es eigentlich
von den faktischen nutzungen herausgibt
geht es vielen so das wäre die eine
frage und die zweite frage ist werden in
der wahlomat forschung auch studierende
eingebunden und wenn ja in welchen
studiengang
okay also zu der ersten frage zu der
frage der treffgenauigkeit
vielleicht hier nochmal
aus der befragung des jahres 2017 also
beim letzten mal aber das sind zahlen
die auch einigermaßen stabil sind über
die verschiedenen versionen hinweg da
haben wir tatsächlich gefragt ist das
ergebnis was sie doch erhalten haben in
irgendeiner form das was sie erwartet
haben also kommen sie sich
wiedergefunden entweder bei der partei
ungefähr in der nähe der partei die sie
normalerweise bevorzugen oder der sie
sich nahe fühlen und wenn man jetzt hier
nochmal sich diese beiden torten
anschaut das sind dort ein diagramm auf
der rechten auf der linken seite ist da
geht ja darum zu fragen wer hat
überhaupt eine klare position erst dann
kann man natürlich sagen man ist
überrascht nicht überrascht wenn man
völlig offen ist kann man nicht
überrascht werden und einen 90 prozent
sagen überhaupt dass die oder sagen eine
klare position zu haben das heißt es
noch schon relativ viele sie meistens
fast alle den wald nutzen aber auch so
eine gewisse
parteipräferenz und von denen sagen
wiederum 70 prozent ja sie sind ungefähr
circa also im lager gelandet wo sie sich
auch von guten und 23 prozent sind genau
dort gelandet bei der partei die sie
erwartet haben ist natürlich wirklich
wenn sie so viele parteien in einem tool
haben wir einmal schwierig vielleicht
genau dort zu landen aber ungefähr ist
also schon mal um diese partei herum
vielleicht der senat stehen und nur 6,6
prozent hier 20 17 haben gesagt sie sind
völlig überrascht wurden von dem
ergebnis was ihn angezeigt worden ist
also so weit erst mal wir können also
den zahlen er sehen dass tatsächlich die
meisten dort landen wo sie sich ungefähr
vermuten also diesen überraschungseffekt
man dort eben aber ist zumindest nicht
so dominant dass er sich bei uns in den
zahlen zum ausdruck bringen würde die
zweite frage ist studierenden ja machen
die mit könnt ihr mitmachen klar auf
jeden fall wir haben ein team hier der
wahlomat forschung da sind ja auch
studierende drin also als damals
angestellt als hilfskräfte wir machen
aber auch veranstaltungen zum thema
wahlomat ist klar masterarbeiten
bachelorarbeiten die gelaufen sind zum
thema wahlomat in den studiengängen
an der uni düsseldorf haben das spiel
gegangen sozialwissenschaften und dann
der studie politische kommunikation und
da spielt das nun eine rolle für uns das
nicht überspannen das sind wirklich
schönes tool wo man forschen machen kann
und gleichzeitig aber auch politische
bildung mit betragen kann insofern
nutzen wir auch diese potenziale dieses
tool hat auch in dem bereich der
wissenschaftlichen forschung die wir
hier betragen und der lehre die bilder
stephan dazu wir haben den chat an noch
mal den link zur wahlomat forschung
reingeschrieben da findet man sehr viele
auch der pdfs auch die die lokale
gezeigt hast auch wirklich für die
letzten jahre und jahrzehnte nochmal
entsprechend zusammengefasst und ja noch
mal ganz klar in der stelle glaube ich
zusammengefasst der hinweis den
allermeisten geht es mit dem
überraschungseffekt nicht so also die
allermeisten kommen dort in etwa an wo
sie selber sich verorten ich habe es
auch mit thomas krüger im vorfeld noch
mal gesprochen er sagt er kommt
eigentlich auch immer da an außer
vielleicht manchmal bei landtagswahlen
da ist man nicht so ganz so tief drin in
den themen da ist es gibt wohl häufiger
mal so anwendungen aber in der regel
kommt man da an wo man denkt dass man
ankommen soll jetzt gibt es eine frage
von axel hofmann der fragt wie reagieren
sie auf kritik dass der wahlomat durch
die begrenzte zahl der
antwortmöglichkeiten
vor allem durch rechtslastige parteien
leicht ausgetrickst werden könnte ist
jetzt meine these stimmt er dem
überhaupt zu oder wie stellt ihr euch
dazu vielleicht pamela oder martin
also die ab 30 thesen sind nicht viel
aber im vergleich zu internationalen
tools wo es ähnliche tools gibt sind wir
schon an der spitze normalerweise gibt
es immer so 20 bis 25 thesen den anderen
ländern
38 thesen sind
dauernd zehn minuten für die userinnen
und user im bad ist relativ lang für ein
tool im internet aber es wird gerne
genutzt und man sieht es an den
ergebnissen die provisorische gerade
ärzte gezeigt hat dass die meisten
menschen aus ihren erwartungen heraus
dort ankommen wo sie sich vorher
verortet haben also rechts links überall
also die sind ja nicht alle in class
einer position was ich brauche doch kurz
dazwischen gehen weil ich glaube sie
haben die frage etwas missverstanden es
geht nicht um die zahl der thesen
sondern die zahl der
antwortmöglichkeiten
also das war zum beispiel bei jahr oder
neuen cara prüfungsmöglichkeiten hat
sondern sorgen kann
das ist interessant für alle parteien
glaube ich sie wir sagen den parteien
sollen also es wäre gut wenn sie sich
positionieren ja oder nein aber sie
haben natürlich die freie wahl auch
neutral zu nehmen und die begründung zu
schreiben wir überprüfen ob die
begründung mit der mit dem votum
übereinstimmt ist macht das team der uni
düsseldorf anschaut ist sie stimme zu
einer partei mit der begründung diese
geben eigentlich stimmig oder gibt es da
vielleicht eine missdeutung ein
missverständnis
wir haben die erfahrung gemacht dass
parteien die versucht haben
eventuell so zu antworten dass sie
dachten das kommt besser an und in ihrer
begründung vielleicht nicht ganz genau
waren vor allen dingen von ihrer
wählerschaft von vielen usern des wahl o
maten darauf hingewiesen wurden wenn es
nicht stimmig war und deshalb das war
ganz am anfang das war nun mal so und
das haben sich sehr dass dieses mediale
aber ich nur aber auch das echo der
nutzerinnen und nutzer des wahl o mat
die darauf aufmerksam gemacht haben wenn
etwas nicht stimmig war so enorm für die
parteispitzen auch im feedback das
schon gesehen dass die parteien im banat
vergleichsweise authentisch antworten
also dieser sie müssen ja auch mit ihrem
namen mit ihrem programm dafür stehen
und da sind die user wenn es letzten
beim letzten wahlomat die bundestagswahl
als 15,7 millionen nutzung die gucken
sehr genau auf die antworten der
parteien die begründung und geben das
sehr schnell weiter es ist sehr
transparent
deshalb ist es sehr authentisch
ok dann hätte ich jetzt noch eine frage
die auch immer wieder mal kommt ich
hatte sie übersehen entschuldigungen
eine burkhardt es gibt ja immer wieder
mal kritik an der frage oder es gibt
einen hinweis an der zu der frage warum
gibt es keine version in leichter
sprache oder auch für sehbehinderte die
vielleicht oder zusatzprogramme per
sprachbefehl antworten möchten oder ich
würde die frage vielleicht sogar nochmal
einen dritten aspekt ergänzen warum gibt
es an sich schon keine übersetzung des
romans beispielsweise ins türkische oder
ins dänische oder ins sorbische also in
minderheitensprachen die in deutschland
ja gesprochen werden wie so häufig oder
dänisch was was sagt dir da aber vor
allen dingen jetzt auch mal die frage
auf die barrierefreiheit des wahlomat
wie wie geht ihr damit um
nochmal pamela oder martin ich kann
etwas zur barrierefreiheit sagen
sprachen beim wähler kannst du dann
vielleicht noch daran gehen wir haben
die barrierefreiheit ist tatsächlich in
wald in ein großes ziel für uns das
heißt wenn die technische
barrierefreiheit herzustellen da glaub
ich nicht sagen haben unsere techniker
programmierer lange daran gearbeitet und
intensiv gefeilt und wir wurden
tatsächlich auch in diesem jahr schon
von der
bundesstelle für bei der zur überwachung
der barrierefreiheit geprüft und die hat
uns eine weitgehende barrierefreiheit
für den ball und in sachsen anhalt für
die versionen bescheinigt und auf basis
des briefergebnisses haben wir selbst
noch mal nach gearbeitet und wir haben
jetzt in der letzten woche auch
tatsächlich die letzten schritte gemacht
so dass wir alle alle vorgaben die die
btv 20 die der maßgeblich ist
erfüllen was wir auch im wahl-o-mat
haben was darüber hinausgeht ist eine
vorlesefunktion das heißt jemand der
der mit den den thesen zu lesen ein
problem hat der kann sich über ein icon
rechts unten im ballon hat das auch
vorlesen lassen was ihnen da an thesen
präsentiert wird und so versuchen wir
die die barrierefreiheit noch besser
darzustellen
habe ich direkt dazu sieben mal
ansprechen weil also das ist ja nicht
der punkt gewesen sondern die awo
kritisiert dass es keine version in
leichter sprache gibt warum nicht und
ich möchte auch gerne wissen warum zum
beispiel sehbehinderte nicht ohne
zusatzprogramm per sprachbefehl
antworten können
oder wird das noch nachgebessert wir
sagen dass jetzt programm also wir sind
mit den übersetzungen in leichter
sprache und einfache sprache waren wir
schon vor jahren mit der aktion mensch
im gespräch mit vielen vereinigung die
das mit uns probiert haben und sich
ausgestellten ihren versuchen und
testläufen die wir dazu gemacht haben
dass das tool wahlomat mit 38 sehr
komplexen thesen nicht so einfach
übersetzt werden kann wir hatten da
mehrere schwierigkeiten auf die wir
gemeinsam gestoßen sind und dann
das ausprobiert haben dh wenn man eine
these nomad übersetzt in einfache
leichte sprache braucht man viele andere
worte eine andere wortwahl man braucht
viele beispiele etwa die thesen
tendenziell länger und sind hier jetzt
schon relativ viel zu lesen muss man
sagen ist der kein leichter stoff und
diese art von neuer wortwahl
übersetzungen für beispiele hat dazu
geführt dass die nuancen der these
anders werden das ist auch bei
übersetzung aller sprachen so gewesen
die haben das auch sehr oft ausprobiert
wir haben auch wahl o maten schon
bereits online gestellt in
minderheitensprachen aber auch in
türkisch und russisch dazu haben wir
gewaltiges feedback bekommen an dem wir
lange lange zeit jetzt schon immer
wieder gearbeitet haben der wahlomat bei
der thesen erstellung auch allein in der
frauen in der sprache die sie jetzt
sehen online ist quasi in unserem
workshop wie ein germanistischen seminar
es kommt jeder auf jede nuance an wenn
man in these stellt zum beispiel früher
nicht mehr gerade aktuell aber zur
atomkraft da ist die frage wann
atomkraftwerk kernkraft nimmt atomkraft
hat man gleich im kopf atomkraftgegner
kernkraft hat man wissenschaft im ohr
das ergibt eine neue nuance in diese
these und deshalb muss sehr genau
gewählt werden welchen profit mann oder
welches werk nutzt man welches adjektiv
welche beispiel indem man zum beispiel
selbstständige
berufsgruppen für selbstständige und
gewerbesteuer zu nehmen all diese
beispiele und all diese worte werben
genauso auch
worte die eventuell von bestimmten
politischen richtung auch besetzt sein
könnten oder auch so empfunden werden
können sind sehr genau überprüft und
diskutiert worden bei einer beisetzung
an einsprachen auch in leichter sprache
weil es immer wieder das problem dass
wir dadurch die diese ursprungs diese so
sehr verändert haben in nuancen dass
nicht nur die parteien dazu durch diese
übersetzungsleistung sich anders
positionierte sondern auch die userinnen
und user das anders wahrgenommen haben
also die übersetzung war tatsächlich
nicht deckungsgleich mit unserer
original these da wir aber der sehr
genau sind und genau diese diesen
abgleich auch für alle versionen haben
wollen können wir das in dieser form
nicht leisten deshalb waren wir lange
nach einer suche und sind es leider noch
dass wir ein anderes tool entwickeln
müssen in leichter oder einfacher
sprache weil 38 thesen zu übersetzen die
dann sehr sehr lang werden und dann eben
diese deckungsgleiche nicht erreichen
können das ist uns bislang nach all
unseren jahre lang versuchen mich
möglich gewesen mit dem
spracheingabe funktion ist es so das ist
ja wie bei anderen spracheingabe
funktionen auch wenn man über so was
geht wie siri oder alexa dann haben wir
ein datenschutzproblem in der form dass
diese dinge gespeichert werden müssen
die eingaben müssen irgendwo abgelegt
werden wir sind in dem war domat sehr
genau darauf bedacht dass keinerlei
daten gespeichert werden es ist
keinerlei möglichkeiten gibt diese
irgendwie zu hacken und zu generieren
und weiterzugeben und deshalb sind wir
haben wir uns zum einen erst mal auf
diese sprachversion konzentriert die
können wir ausgeben da gibt es dann das
feedback nicht was dann gespeichert
zusammengeklappt werden muss
ok vielen dank an jeder nochmal zudem
antworten in dieser in diesem
fragenkomplex euch allen schon mal an
dieser stelle sozusagen vom podium
herzlichen dank es gibt noch eine ganze
reihe von kleineren nachfragen ich habe
die mir auch schon angeschaut ich würde
jetzt folgendes vorstellen wir sind
jetzt eine dreiviertel stunde durch den
offiziellen teil der pressekonferenz
durch mein vorschlag ist dass wir uns
jetzt in entsprechende breakout ruhms
hineinbegeben und zwar haben wir zum
einen aus der vielköpfigen jugend und
überhaupt redaktion des wahl o mats
verschiedene redakteurin der redakteure
eingeladen heute mit dabei zu sein und
fünf räume wo man also auf jüngere
redakteurinnen und redakteure des
wahl-o-mat treffen kann 1 bis 5 und wir
haben einen raum mit der projektleitung
wo sie noch mal auch intensivere
vertragen stellen können und es gibt
einen raum wo man professor stefan
escher nochmal treffen kann das heißt
ich öffne jetzt die räume und sie können
sich selber gerne diesen räumen zu
weisen einen anderen herzen dank ist sie
schon jetzt dabei waren bei der wahl o
mat